[Music]
they come with an unusual name and
they're here to teach kids how to
express themselves Bubble Guppies are so
popular they even have their own live
rock show stick until the end to see
what your favorite characters look like
in real life don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe
today we're checking out 10 Bubble
Guppies characters in real life
una una is a very sweet preschooler her
purple hair makes her stand out from the
others but it's her sweet looks that
instantly make you want to be her friend
she usually hangs out with one of the
characters will mention laughed but
she's easily friends with everyone
una is there to teach us the excitement
of knowledge she's always excited when
she learns a new thing from mr. grouper
and that's why we love her check out
this little cutie totally rocking the
una look una sports an entirely purple
outfit if you like her adorable look
wait until you see some of the other
Bubble Guppies characters we'll show you
here are a few more real-life una kids
that totally nailed her look and are
really rocking the purple hair several
of them could easily pass as a complete
human look-alike all they need to do now
is sing in a high-pitched voice and
dance to make it on the Bubble Guppies
rock show from what it looks like it
seems these real-life una characters
would have no issues fitting in the
world of these aqua preschoolers they do
make us want to melt our hearts though
because they're just so adorable here's
the original voice behind una and her
name is Reina sha scam Molly
Molly's character is very similar to
Anna she's known as the leader of the
group and she's always kind and helpful
her character teaches children the
importance of helping each other when in
need check out these awesome real-life
Molly costumes
Molly usually wears awesome looking pink
hair
and has a Blue Mermaid outfit these kids
are totally rockin the blue outfit and
some are even wearing a complete mermaid
suit although Molly's a natural-born
leader and the attention is always on
her her character also teaches not to
take that attention and be selfish
Molly's the pop singer in the show with
a very strong voice these cuties would
definitely do well in the Bubble Guppies
rock show their costumes are totally on
fleek check out this one whose costume
is hand-sewn molly is clearly a very
popular character and we absolutely love
all these real-life Bubble Guppies
characters the original molly is voiced
by Brianna gentle Ella who doesn't have
pink hair but she's responsible for
making her characters sound totally
awesome since the show started in 2011
although we're pretty sure these little
cosplayers could give the animated Molly
a run for her money
and take her spot if they'd have to if
we had to pick our favorite it'd have to
be this little cutie Gil and Molly
Bubble Guppies appear in groups most of
the time so let's have a look at Gil and
Molly
we'll talk more about Gil in a while but
the two deserve to be featured on our
video together
Gil and Molly are best friends and out
of everyone on the show they're the
closest they're both good singers who
usually stick to pop songs and there
seems to be some sort of a romance
blossoming between the two Gil and Molly
couldn't be more opposite from each
other
Gil has fluorescent blue hair and a
green mermaid tail while Molly has pink
hair and a blue outfit they even have
cute nicknames for each other as Molly's
the only character that calls Gil
Gilly isn't that just the most adorable
thing ever here they are in their real
life form these are the actual costumes
you'd see if you ever attend a Bubble
Guppies rock show check them out here
singing a duet together looking totally
adorable and here they are again rockin
the audience like no one else can
these two really are hashtag friendship
goals fans of the show have suspected
romance happened between the two but
since these aqua creatures are supposed
to be only preschoolers it's safe to say
these two are really just the bestest of
friends crabs the scarlet red colored
crabs are characters that work in the
hospital but you can also find them in
other professions on the show they come
with two large claws and six small legs
but their outfits depend on where they
work even though their background
characters they make us giggle with
sayings like call a clambulance they're
ready to help out anyone in need and
make sure everyone is happy and has a
good time check out this amazing crab
cosplay she's absolutely adorable isn't
she you might want to look away if
you're squeamish but here's what a
real-life crab would look like unlike
the characters you see on Bubble Guppies
crabs usually have ten legs as they
belong to the Dakota family and while a
real-life crab doesn't look that
exciting these human crab characters are
definitely entertaining how can you even
resist a cute looking crab like this one
there are many types of real-life crabs
and their size varies but they do have a
couple of things in common with the
crabs from Bubble Guppies did you know
that some crab types are actually super
caring and can be huge neat freaks
no wonder the crabs in Bubble Guppies
work in a hospital and always make sure
people are having a good time
would you prefer seeing a real-life crab
or dressing up in one of these cute
looking crab costumes rooper l' grew
pearl has to be one of our favorite
characters out there and if you're
familiar with RuPaul's Drag Race you
already know the real-life version of
rooper l' the real-life roux pearl was
in fact based on the popular american
actor RuPaul best known for being the
host of RuPaul's Drag Race
RuPaul also voices rooper and although
she only appears in a single Bubble
Guppies episode it's the one that's the
most iconic rooh pearl is a host of a
boxing event in an episode called
costume boxing that's pretty much all we
know about her but we do know a bit more
about her real-life version
Paul root pearls look is inspired by
drag queens did you know that a total of
113 Queens have competed on the show up
until 2017 the show revolves around the
glamorous life of drag queen as they
compete to be the ultimate winner of
RuPaul's Drag Race along with being able
to watch drag queens in their element
the show also teaches people about the
importance of self-love RuPaul even won
an Emmy for an outstanding host for a
reality or reality-competition program
in 2016 it's safe to say that RuPaul is
adored but so is Rupert and we just wish
we were able to see more of her in
Bubble Guppies as we're sure she could
definitely lip sync for her life stage
fishy
although Sid fishy is just a side
character that appeared in a single
episode you have to admit he's
absolutely hilarious if you've watched
the show you probably noticed he sounds
familiar and we bet you couldn't figure
out from where there's a reason behind
his mohawk he's voiced by the one and
only Ozzy Osbourne there's no actual
fish that would look similar to Sid
fishy but check it out it looks like
both Ozzy and Sid fish share the same
smile and they really do look similar in
this photo Ozzy is a controversial
singer that's been around since 1970 as
the lead vocalist of the Black Sabbath
since then he became known as one of the
wildest man of the rock age you might
have also heard of his wife Sharon
Osbourne the two are no strangers to
show business and they're definitely
doing very well for themselves now Ozzy
Osbourne still plays music but we'd love
to see him voicing a few more characters
like Sid fishy in Bubble Guppies
Sid fishies a rock and roll fish who
loves being Roberts and if you're a fan
of Ozzy you know that his personality
perfectly fits this description
stylee Bubble Guppies has a lot of
colorful characters and stylee is Noack
option this aqua creature is rocking
white shoulder-length hair and black and
white glasses but she also frequently
changes her style she is stylee after
all she worries what other people might
think and expect of her but she's
actually a world famous pop star we know
of two people who look like a real
lifestyle II and we bet you know who
they are one of them has a
black-and-white wig and is a popular
singer the other has the same wig but
she's an incredible dancer yep it's SIA
and Maddie Ziegler don't the two look
like the perfect characters for stylee
stylee especially looks like Maddie from
the chandelier video just add some
glasses and voila
it's stylee from Bubble Guppies stylee's
original voice belongs to keke palmer
who's also known to be quite the
fashionista out of the three who do you
think would be the best-looking stylee
we're giving our word to Maddie Ziegler
Maddie has had several TV opportunities
in the past few years and we can
definitely see her doing more and more
voiceover roles we can definitely see a
character like stylee appear again in
other cartoons nany Bubble Guppies are
so adorable it's really hard to pick our
favorite as they're all special in their
own way but one of the cutest characters
on Bubble Guppies is Nani Nani is the
ginger-haired intelligent and very calm
guppy
he is known to use advanced vocabulary
for his age and he always reacts calmly
under pressure
mr. cautious is his original nickname
but Nani is also known as the bookworm
of the group you have to admit he's
absolutely the cutest thing ever
here's the real-life version of Nani
this costume is pretty awesome
and we love that we're finally seeing
some boy character in Bubble Guppies but
don't worry
Nani is not the only boy in this gang
speaking of real-life Bubble Guppies
characters we think Ron Weasley from
Harry Potter would make a fantastic
real-life nonny Ron's personality would
definitely fit Nanni's and you have to
admit that you love his ginger hair in
the haunted house party episode nonny
can actually be seen wearing a cloak so
a wizard look definitely suits him
here's the actual real-life nonny rockin
it out on the Bubble Guppies Show where
he plays instruments more than he sings
this character really is adorable
and we'd love to see Ron Weasley put on
a mermaid outfit grab a guitar and
become nonny Deema how can you not love
Deema and her unique blonde hair it's
known that her personality is as big as
her hair and she's definitely one of the
most popular characters on the show you
can't really blame her because she looks
absolutely fantastic
she's always over-the-top and likes to
exaggerate her emotions to the point
where her nickname is drama queen we
love her poufy 70s style hair and her
big personality is what makes this show
fantastic it's clear that Deema has a
lot of fans and here are some real-life
examples of this awesome guppy the first
one really did an amazing job with her
outfit which includes perfectly
recreated big hair the second shot is
actually pretty cool as it's taken
underwater but wait there's more here
are real-life Deema and Oona posing
together it's not just the most adorable
thing you've ever seen
and check out the actual real-life Deema
behind nonny looking like she's
definitely ready to rock there's another
Bubble Guppies character that would
definitely Rock the Deema look it's
Rupert who'd look amazing in dmoz big
puffy hair it must take some serious
hairspray to make Deemas hair stay this
way while still underwater and we'd love
to get some hair styling tips from this
energetic Bubble Guppies Gil and last
but not least let's talk about one of
the most hyper Guppies out there Gil is
always up for anything he's curious and
he's usually the one that encourages the
entire group to join his adventures this
blue haired green-tailed creature is
one of the cutest and most popular
characters on the show he shows the
audience that it's okay to be excitable
and energetic if you know a toddler who
loves Gil this is the perfect costume to
use to recreate a real-life version of
the popular character
here's another impressive Gil chilling
on the beach and his mermaid outfit his
hair looks pretty awesome and makes him
stand out from the crowd
Gil is voiced by Zachary Gordon who
actually looks a lot like his character
just put on a blue wig dress him in a
green mermaid outfit and there he is
we know Gil is best friends with Molly
who's also a very popular character Gil
loves to sing and can play many
instruments including guitar and drums
which comes in handy on the show piri is
again singing his duet with Molly his
blue hair definitely reflects his
energetic personality and his curiosity
for adventure is contagious
we all need a friend like Gil in our
lives and that's it for 10 Bubble
Guppies characters in real life for more
videos like this one check out 10
wreckit-ralph characters in real life
see you next time
[Music]